[Music]
thank you
all right
hello welcome it is September 2nd 2022.
and we're in active live stream number
48.0
welcome to the active inference
Institute we're a participatory online
Institute that is communicating learning
and practicing applied active inference
this is a recorded in archive live
stream so please provide feedback so we
can improve our work
all backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome and we'll be following video
etiquette for live streams
head to
activeinference.org or
activeinference.institute to come to our
website learn more
we are in active stream number 48 series
we're going to be discussing the paper
communication as socially extended
active inference and ecological approach
to communicative Behavior paper in 2021
by Remy Tucson and pierre-poyer the
video is a total introduction to some of
these ideas it's not a review or uh
capturing every aspect for that you can
read the paper and explore some of the
ideas
we are going to talk about aims and
claims abstract roadmap keywords and
bring up some notable points
it is still upcoming with the 48.1 and
48.2 so people are welcome to submit
questions or things to discuss write
comments and join the panel's live if
they want
so
let's begin with introductions and
warm-up I think we can share more uh
with our big question so Dean why don't
you say hello and introduce your big
question
thanks Daniel I'm Dina I'm here in
Calgary and um
well I could I could read out the big
question but it's pretty long-winded so
I'll just say that I'm always curious
about what happens when active inference
isn't something that we look at as a
subject or a topic but it's something
that we actually use or perceive as
being around us and so I think the
question of whether or not
you focus on what's inside of an
ecological space or or look at the
ecology and the system in which we
believe active inference
um
exists as and and maybe at within
because we in the 47 last 47 live stream
we kind of touched on the idea it could
be both
if we're gonna if we're going to expand
our Horizons and look at what kind of
limits are and describe that as an
ecology
um my question then is
as communication and of communication
what is the product of communication and
what is communication serve as so those
are kind of my big questions and I hope
in the next three live streams we can
start maybe at least staking out
where that ecology begins and ends
nice well very interesting thanks a lot
also for so much of the preparation here
we're uh still coming down off of 47 and
so I think it's gonna be interesting to
see how we approach pragmatism in this
discussions
so the big questions that brought me to
this paper or that I was thinking about
during the paper were what are the
applications and implications of
different interpretations of
communication
why does it matter what would be the
things in the world including the mind
that would be changed
as a factor with or Downstream of how
our interpretation of communication is
and then what are the causes and
consequences of different perspectives
we take on active inference where
perspective also includes action
propensity
and engagement with so perspective is
like where one is situated to end
viewing and so it's the view from
somewhere from something
rather than uh view from nowhere slash
everywhere and I think in that
specificity
we can uh have a lot of discussions
about ecology
as a great system to learn from Dean
yeah I think when we're outside or if we
perceive ourselves or we're we're
framing that would be the on this slide
that would be the first box
that's our sense that we're kind of
outside of the system looking in
whereas the the second box on the right
would be well we're embedded and now the
the the reason we're embedded is is the
genie came out got out and now it's all
around us it's kind of like
that the perfume has now been
distributed through the air and now
we're walking through it so which of
those two things depending upon how we
want to analyze which of those two
things produce what results sort of
thing and I think we're both kind of
asking the same question If This Then
what if that
then what
all right
I'll read the first half the abstract
in this paper we introduce an ecological
account of communication According to
which acts of communication are active
inferences achieved by affecting the
behavior of Target organism via the
modification of its field of affordances
constraining a Target organism's
Behavior constitutes a mechanism of
socially extended active inference
allowing organisms to proactively
regulate their interstates through the
behavior of other organisms
in this General conception of
communication the type of Cooperative
communication characteristic of human
communicative interaction is a way of
constraining interaction Dynamics
towards the goals of a given joint
action
by constructing and altering
shared fields of affordances this
account Embraces a pragmatist View
According to which communication is a
form of action aiming to influence the
behavior of a Target and stands against
the traditional transmission View
uh sorry I just have to pull it up here
because it kind of slid on my screen
where am I transmission view According
to which communication fundamentally
searched convey information
understanding acts of communication is
active inference under this ecological
interpretation allows us to link
communicative and ultimately linguistic
Behavior
to the biological imperative and
minimize free energy and emphasize the
action-oriented nature of communicative
action
interactions
all right nice
here's the roadmap and there's some
light sometimes consistent highlighting
at Play
the paper is prose based there are not
any figures or formalisms however many
are suggested so we'll have a
interesting time I think making some
representations using words maybe some
non-linguistic communication because
there's so much to add it's not
providing visual centers as many papers
outside of especially philosophy do so
first there's an introduction then the
central distinction or dialectic or
division is introduced the transmission
and the influencing the and versus but
or
the contrary to negations that we've
kind of explored this time that type of
a dyadic comparison is being brought to
two views of communication
two supporting Witnesses join
which are ecological interpretation the
ecological developments and the turn in
that area
and active inference
and they're going to then in
communication active inference focusing
on human Cooperative communication
describe how under ecological and active
inference starting points Justified
starting points as they'll argue that we
can endorse a pragmatist View
at the detriment to the transmission
View
any other thoughts yes
the authors are pretty clear they they
describe this paper or these arguments
as a sketch
so when we say roadmap here I think that
it's more of uh
um
it's it's it's not a a highly detailed
highly specified uh zoom in on a on a
you know very precise Google Map this is
kind of a back of the napkin idea for
for a conversation starter and so I
appreciate that because I mean at least
by the authors saying um we want to get
this down we want to stake this out and
then let people decide how to come at
this empirically to maybe fill in some
more of the Precision
yep it's like planning a road trip uh in
its implications especially without
itself is an entire completed work
um let's just jump to the aims
well the top two aims are some of the
largest they summarize their work as
introducing a pragmatist conception of
communication grounded in Ecology of
active inference so the three threads
are pragmatism ecological interpretation
and active inference about communication
and they're going to argue that all of
communication be understood as socially
extended active inference
be understood by whom when
and uh those are some of the points it
brings us to
secondly there are some direct
contradictions slash tensions
described and
um contrasting with the transmission
view which is the uh the dancing partner
of the advance of the ecological
pragmatic active view is to con is by
contrast with the transmission View
which can help a lot with literature
continuity
in in uh setting direction for research
field people looking for transmission
view can see that there's a paper
from 2021 that's that's connecting and
finding concordances and as Dean
mentioned they will stress in several
different ways that it's an initial
account
with many gestured two next directions
that we'll get to any other thoughts yes
yeah I I think without using these terms
they're they're saying um
you know there are nodes out there
there's there are connect there are
potential for connections out there one
way of viewing that is through a
transmission line and what we would like
to do is maybe
um
Advance the idea that those links are
are a little bit more embellished than
something simple and so again those
aren't the terms that they use but we've
uh Daniel you're better at this than I
am we had a recent live stream this year
I think where we talked about offloading
as being a really important part of
extending the active inference
okay
um remember which one that was
um kind of yeah yeah extended something
was extended let's look
yeah it was with a cognitive offloading
cognitive communicate um this is 48 oh
extended active inference constructing
predictive cognition Beyond skulls
number 41. right and that and that and
that live stream there wasn't really
there wasn't anything in that idea that
the betweenness
what was like the whole idea of how how
a Markov blanket May function
as as a way of of focusing or bringing
down the amount of noise and raising up
the amount of signal in a in a space
outside yourself there was no
we didn't have a lot of pushback on how
that theoretically would work so I don't
think that they're stepping into that
Zone by by mentioning this nice all
right
so they make several claims they're
summarized here but we'll we'll deal
them in
the sections in rough order anything to
add though okay
they're gonna come up yeah yeah these
are some summaries of some important
claims but we're going to come up with
them soon all right and then last last
stop before we jump into the background
which is one term and then the paper
itself what are the keywords in your eye
well I mean
we we had dynamical systems model in the
last live stream too so there's a lot of
people that are are depending on that
theory to advance whatever arguments
they want to make
um and the other I think the other term
that comes up quite often is joint
actions
without really getting into some hard
specifics about what that might look
like on a scale friendly level so I
think when the authors join us I think
both of those things are things will
have there's fertile ground there to to
grow some conversations
awesome the the one I would just want to
highlight is
dynamical systems model you you
mentioned how
maybe just rephrasing that people use it
to in a lot of different ways and it
just that being raised made me think
about
what is being Advanced by claiming that
alone or together something changes
Through Time
does anyone disagree and would it matter
that everyone disagrees but what does
dynamical mean when we're talking about
time dependent real existing systems
what does it mean that you have a system
or a model or a systems model
what does that mean because that's
something that's an artifact or is it a
quote mental model
and so there's a lot to explore about
what is being meant by dynamical systems
model
we're thinking about time
or does it mean something more than that
continuous time discrete time
implementation effects
there's so many aspects to it and it's
actually going to come back at the very
end all right
and pragmatics
also the top part you could mention
anything otherwise Dean how does this
connect to what we discussed in 47
well I kind of wrote this out so I'd
rather read it um practices of an
interception especially the question of
what makes up an aim and I put in behind
in that the act that act the process
and aiming which is the stand for lining
which is we all know is the generative
model given targeting with what there's
still a question of what are we
targeting with when we when we put it
all under one umbrella called active
inference a situational analysis tool
this this is we've had lots and lots of
people claim that that's what's that's
what active inference is it's a range
finder with a depth of filter or is
active inference an importance generator
something that enables as collection
given through Framing and step
stabilization or both now if you want to
write an academic paper it's way easier
to just limit it to active inferences to
stabilizer now we have t0 T1 T2 and so
on but it's also a way to delimit that
temporal spatial temporal field so do we
just ignore that because it's easier to
write papers if we do
that's where the arrow of time meaning
we're kind of moving with the flow and
temporal depth through the memorial and
across the spec the spectral
uh range whatever we arbitrarily pick as
our projectional integration space
must both be induced or included in
whatever the representational is if we
analyze the entanglement along with the
entailment
so what is the relationship is I mean is
a relationship in the passing Rings no
of course it isn't but those symbols
still reinforce what's going on so can
we just say there's no
representationalism in this
it would be hard to do that on realistic
scales
that would be pragmatics in a nutshell
to me
very interesting
closure
well especially if you're if you're
recently involved in a in a long lasting
long-term relationship right
it's so true
um yeah the part I'll point out is just
a few highlighted words on the top
with a lot of citations provided
that are going to be taking a pragmatic
Federation approach broadly disparate
interests and Foci that are being used
by these authors in their advancement of
an anti-transmission view distributed
language hypothesis constraint view of
language participatory sense making
framework
maybe those fields are or aren't
connected in their citations or
co-authorship but then the authors are
able to connect these as kind of three
people pointing at the same process or
thing and that's like a
nice dense usage that could be really
catching people up on a few ways to
navigate these topics because there's a
lot of related topics it's like aren't
we just talking about how things are
including how modeling is
um they begin in the introduction with
an overview of the
layout of their paper
and they describe as Dean mentioned the
sketch
it's a pragmatist account of
communicative Behavior grounded in
ecological interpretation of
the active inference framework
contrasted with a transmission view of
communication According to which the
function of communicative behavior is to
convey information
so
a claim is that communication is about
information transmission
then they are contrasting that in light
of ecological psychology and Theory
broadly
and also giving an active inference
twist slash Theory integration
slash introduction of free energy
minimization or uncertainty reduction as
imperatives or modeling imperatives or
existence imperatives
whereas some of these previous threads
like ecological psychology more
neutrally wouldn't have necessarily a
formal or a first principle's way
to connect to Modern applications
though they may have a first principles
grounding in pragmatism
so many of the pieces have already been
assembled in terms of the ecological and
pragmatic and Echo and all of these
areas coming together
outside of the paper and so that will be
a theme what is linking out to other
empirical and philosophical literature
what is active inference doing in this
mediation as a framework
something that makes it an organized
principle organizing principle in a way
that merely the literature Corpus
of these areas which in many respects
have been connected
like the pragmatics of linguistics
so what does active inference doing
anything to add on that
well I I I again I don't think it's hard
to argue that um
to focus only on the string and the two
cups is probably reducing too far when
we're talking about communication I mean
they're they're entangles right like
they're now tied together but what the
authors are trying to point out here is
that there also are signalers and Signal
receivers in it and and as soon as you
add more layers to this of what's
actually going on suddenly an ecology
emerges so let's step back and look at
everything that is possibly
participating in this not just the
hardware and so again it will be hard to
argue against that at the same time
um if you and I don't have all of the
all of the things that we need to
communicate from Davis California to
Calgary Canada no matter how much we
screen there's no communication there's
no live stream 48 right now so again
to dismiss a transmission view I think
is also probably not the best idea in
the world because without that what do
you got
yep good point and they'll bring up that
sort of enabling system perspective in
the conclusion very clearly
yeah they set up the perspective of
communication as transmitting
information
symbolic information or other kinds of
information influencing
sculpting what is it influencing is it
modifying cognitive dials is it
modifying the field of affordances
is it doing both is it
any number of
ways that people have been studying
Nexus of communication
intra species interpersonally
everything
and you've done it I was going to say if
you read if you've read anything from
Charles Saunders Pierce you would have
to say it's both
like you you I mean if you're a first
follower you're not left with much
choice because there's a lot of
influencing going on because there's a
lot of interpreting happening
yeah
awesome
all right setting the context
do you want to mention it or do you want
me to mention it go for it all right
well the first footnote is about the
notion of information
and they describe different information
and uncertainty
Concepts
which we can address in later
discussions
they do not dedicate a lot of time and
space to
fleshing out the transmission View and
different ways that people off formally
informally addressed it causes and
consequences Etc however they have
provided a lot of citations
then in footnote 4
they are describing fridge
a writing in the 1890s
which is a very interesting connection I
don't know the details but some
information is provided in this section
footnote
it's an interesting path it'd be fun to
kind of go down more because we've now
brought back in Paris
to the discussion as others are and I
think walking the fine line between not
using last names for equations
while respecting the process and
contributions of past
researchers and and practitioners in
just different areas
will be really
part of what active inference brings
together
all right anything else
all I would say is that I I think what
this maybe points out again this is not
what they wrote in their uh notes but
with every transmission there are things
like conflict embedded in that or
complexity embedded in that I mean any
any good writer knows that you can't
just transmit a bunch of information
there are there are expectations around
what what are you moving towards and and
why would I continue to communicate and
so you have to have a context around
which that that continuing
um regime of attention is held up
yep share attention regime is of
attention joint action
um so setting the logic here they are
going to flesh out two primary reasons
to explore theoretical alternatives to
TV so not they're wrong they thought bad
but there are two reasons to explore
we're at camp and we're going to explore
some theoretical
alternatives
firstly TV entails a commitment to an
account
of the putative contents conveyed via
communication
providing such an account is notoriously
difficult especially if linguistic
practices cannot be invoked as part of
the explanation
very
deep points about what is linguistically
accessible consciously accessible
perceptible under difference
situations
through different kinds of memory and
anticipation
and
all these features which we know do play
roles in
semiosis
and then the seconds reason why to
explore a theoretical alternative is how
it's not clear that communication
conceived of as the transmission of
content could be relevant to the basic
allostatic processes which Drive the
behavior of organisms so you might say
biosemiotically the pancreas
communicates with different cells in the
body through hormone signaling
but in a transmission view would one be
committed to the Viewpoint insulin means
do x y z
to whom
under what conditions in what ways is
that a communication so especially at
scales and systems that aren't quite
literally humans talking about language
which is quite common
then
there's going to be an account that's
non-linguistic
so to what extent are we going to
privilege or Center
this type of linguistic discourse in
communication
in a broader Ecology of communication
right so if the content by itself can't
direct cannot
help us derive meaning than what this
essentially is saying is is that we need
more than that in order to get the equal
sign or symbol to
equate to meaning right so that's all
essentially what they're trying to talk
about here is if we're going to go past
TV why
yeah it could be a supplement to TV or
an extension of TV which yeah as they'll
point out later can never be denied or
rejected so then pragmatism they trace a
thread of scholarship
in which language is viewed as a form of
action
and I'm reminded of Professor Deborah
Gordon's paper vickenstein and ant
watching
seeing the behavioral ecologist as
they're observing ant Behavior
the multiple stages and steps and ways
that knowing and acting and naming of
different kinds namings of activities as
an association of activities as named
with identities and that naming process
that comes in very late in the game in
terms of the actions taken to prepare
the context for that observation
so I thought that was a very interesting
link and here are those green
highlighted words from earlier so what
else would you add about pragmatism
well I think what what they were
moving towards here at least alerting us
to is that the fact that there are
aspects of a pragmatist view although it
may sound a little strange to say it at
first I think is true at least with a
pragmatist view you can now conjure
things that you can't do simply with
content I mean I can have a whole bunch
of ingredients and not have a recipe but
at least with a pragmatist view now I
can start experimenting and I think
that's all they're basically asking us
to contemplate
it's the experimentation piece it's not
just sort of leaving everything out on
the on the bench and going whoa well I
can take an account of this or an
inventory of it but not really do
anything with it so that's that's what I
took away from this part of the paper
nice
all right here's a discussion around
what signals mean anything to add
no just read it it's pretty straight up
yep
okay
in this section
setting active inference framework we've
informally introduced the ecological
interpretation
of the active inference framework
in the terms of which we will formulate
a pragmatist conception of communication
in section communication and active
inference
when is it of the active inference
framework the genitive case when is it
in the active inference framework the
locative case
with the instrumental case there's so
many
routes to explore with linguistic and
non-linguistic communication
even only keeping with active inference
as the gripper and the gripped right
they provide a description which is
copied here
and one key line that they'll bring back
in service of communication is organisms
can reduce free energy
either by adjusting the sensory input to
the generative model
quote active inference or by adjusting
the generative model to the sensory
input perceptual inference which
correspond respectively to action and
perception
so one could ask whether active
inference only applies to adjusting
sensory input
or what whether action corresponds to
active inference and perception to
perceptual inference that's one way to
think about it it certainly is one sense
of active inference which is inference
about action
planning decision making and also the
consequences of action
being able to introduce preference into
future and current actions
and
we're talking about active inference
also as a framework
for considering this View
so
that was just the connection with active
inference there one connection so the
part so part of this and I'll ask you
because I'll ask let me ask the authors
let me do the dot one is up this stuff
that they just wrote out here because
we've seen this many many times people
just want to make sure that they're
following what the free energy principle
up to this point has this has has
generally been agreed to to mean my
question from that last organisms can
reduce free energy either by so if I
were to give the metaphor of getting the
toothpaste back into the tube
how does communication serve that
purpose
right because it's really really easy to
squeeze it out
but how do how does communication serve
get it back in
because it
it can but how does how does what
they're describing here as an ecological
View
speak to that
let's explore
yeah they then go to the ecological
interpretation of active inference
so after introducing just purely in
principle using some active inference
ontology terms and key ideas like
embodiment of generative models and
reduction of surprisal bounding that
through variational and expected free
energy
they
continue to add in ingredients to the
recipe
and uh
contrast a abstract Theory neutral
description
of active inference
which is their
framing of Act of vanilla or Standalone
or somehow
perhaps archetypal octave inference as
being Theory neutral
and hence compatible and therefore
compatible with many conceptions of
cognition
pointing to a citation where it's
described as a state Theory compatible
with many different process theories
which is why potentially someone
could and probably has argued for a
transmission View using active inference
as symbolic communication or semantic
communication or there's probably so
many
angles on that we know we could explore
um
bringing in the ecological papers
citing some of the earlier ecological
psychology
and perceptual work
in predictive processing and then just
connecting it to more recent papers for
example brunberg kerstein ritvelt
ramstead many of these authors
collaborations in about the past six
years
anything else dad
well I got some notes that I want to
talk about in The Dot one but I think
this is interesting because
um
it would be at this point where if they
wanted to introduce formalisms which
basically are just a bunch of symbols
set up operationally that they could but
they haven't so how do we explain or how
do we take into account all of those
formulas that we've looked at
throughout a number of live streams if
we're stop if we're talking about
something that's ecological
because they are there
so
so are they floating around us or are
they only something that we keep inside
of a very contained very constrained
very
condition set aspect of this of this
diverse very complex
um
situation that we find ourselves under
so yeah that when you as soon as you say
of I would I would assume that one of
the products of an ecological
interpretation would be a whole month to
formalisms
because you could derive those pretty
well I can't I'm not Carl or or Thomas
or one of those you know super math
people that they can so so what do we
how do we
how do we account for that
yeah one note on that is some of the
famous models of Predator prey type
Dynamics are those dynamical equations
are used in neuroimaging to model for
example winner list competitions amongst
brain regions or with different
signaling regimes so in many ways the
SPM package specifically as well as
Neuroscience more broadly
many threads and precursors are here
which
is why I really appreciate that
um you by interpreting
the way you are about how active
inference is being interpreted
there aren't just the bullet point or
the visual abstract
of
active inference if it that is the
active inference
that is the interpretation of the
authors
using active inference
like they're working through it and
making a trace in a process
versus just saying well this is the
Standalone author independent
interpretation
I'm not sure if that makes sense but
all right
this uh here's some text on a slide
to look at connecting uh
spatial temporal structure of
affordances in ecological settings
the concept known as field of
affordances or the landscape of
affordances
and different affordances different
kinds of action capacity
introducing how salience and attention
and proclivity towards an affordance
is determined by its free energy by the
free energy is expected to reduce
by the system entity or by the modeler
um
and there's a few more notes on
ecological psychology and affordances
sentence in the last bullet there I
think it's I think it's really important
too again to go back to the I won't ask
you to go back to the previous slide but
we don't carry around this
formalisms and those operations with us
but humans become attuned to social
affords by being immersed in and
participating in shared social cultural
practice
just very early in their development
that that seems pretty obvious this
immersion leads to the integration of a
social physics okay well then there is
math involved in this
which is the set of structured and
systemic social contingencies available
in an environment of development so even
if we can't identify what those
formalisms are those formalisms must be
present in order for this early this
thing that we call early development and
integration to exist it can't just be
met it can't just you can't just say
it's oh it's there but we can't explain
it there actually is something symbolic
and representational they didn't even
even if we can't conjure it ourselves
there are there are those aspects which
we need to to include
right just because I I don't I I don't
think of it as math
doesn't mean the math isn't present
so I think that I think that I think
that's a really important one here in
terms of making their argument
even though it's an ecology there's
still a lot of formalism
that that would seem to be abstract but
presents as as something real so
yeah
my little two cents yes that's a
interesting
Direction and made me think about
attractors Dynamics gravity in Social
settings and that puts quite a
spin on Bayesian mechanics as a social
physics
and sociophysics has been approached
from
um the classical Billiards case from the
statistical thermodynamic informational
case and probably more speculatively by
some from the quantum case so it's those
three mechanics classical statistical
Thermo info and Quantum yeah three five
however many there are
um are what are being proposed in their
integration by Bayesian mechanics which
we'll be discussing in uh
that next live stream actually in 49
with uh some really interesting
formalisms to re-enter into so I think
it's like seeing what's not there but
seeing depth in what they're pointing to
even just by discussing integration of
social physics we don't need to provide
100 citations to social crises or
tragedies
it is just what is
gestured towards with what the domain of
the work is
yeah
all right
in section communication
as socially extended active inference
here's some quotes anything you want to
add
I just want to read bullet three
communication is thus understood as we
might what we might call socially
extended active inference situations
where the organism reduces free energy
by influencing the behavior of another
organism in such a way that it's sensory
input will correspond to the predictions
of its generative model thereby
regulating its own internal states by
the behavior of the other organism
other than through formalism how could
we prove that
would be my question
yeah great question
and uh
what if well there what if there are
many routes
and one can ask somebody to stop
writing on the sidewalk with chalk or
they could just wash it while they're
gardening or they could go in so many
ways it's like the adjacent possible of
the social physics
is open in a way that
contrived or designed settings art
which isn't to say they are useful or or
educational but that's not the same
right the only way you could prove it
though yeah I think is through
representational symbolic
operational like I don't know how
because every time you try to repeat it
someone like Dean comes along and says
oh I think I know what the game is here
I'm going to disrupt the game right so
that there really is only one way to
prove it and so yeah I I I like that
they put this in here now and one of our
colleagues Stephen likes to talk about
the prefixes added to active inference
and so again do we need those prefixes
in order to be able to explain our
argument is it for the convenience of
our argument or do those things really
happen
and can we say can we say they really
happen because we can prove it
all right nice the following section is
some cases of communication
and three areas are highlighted
and for those cases one could ask what
is or could be a transmission view on
that setting or how have people framed a
certain case or instance or type of
communication as transmission View
and then how is an ecological active
inference interpretation
changing that challenging that
going Beyond it and the three areas that
they are looking at are aggressive
behavior
mating or sexual reproductive signaling
and alarm signaling
and they write about in each of these
cases how one might see the type of
behavior exhibited there as kind of a
canonical signaling case like when you
look up signaling you'll find these
keywords describing it as categories of
signaling and communication
and one very excellent book to follow up
on is Helen longedo's 2012 book studying
human behavior how scientists
investigate aggression and sexuality
they're two of the go-to areas in
behavioral study two of the go-to
approaches and phenomena and framings of
action interaction
and this is a very multi and
transdisciplinary book that addresses in
the context of some recent historical
debates around the relevance of genetic
inheritance ecological inheritance
social structuring all these different
topics approached in a really
edifying way I think it speaks to the
gripper and the being gripped which is
kind of the role of what history and
philosophy of science
has been doing
in a disciplinary Academic Way with a
certain approach and time frame and
feedback
method
cool okay
human Cooperative communication
um
anything to add
I'm always curious about
um I put a little note on the on the
actual paper my copy of the paper
um
about cooperation
um and I'm no expert on cooperation so I
I'm sketching this out like the authors
are sketching certain things out but
um
I think this is what I wrote
let me see here
uh yes
neither the um
the transmission version nor the
ecological field of affordance's model
can say for certain how long the
Cooperative state will exist for
which requires a different type of
analysis over the one that confirms that
communication lines are functioning
regardless of function type
so stepping back and saying that there
is a type of communication which we'll
call Cooperative is great
um we can we can say that there's a type
here but just naming it doesn't mean
we've actually tamed or been able to
explain why
that type exists so that's one of those
things again when we have the authors
with this I like to chat about that a
little bit more
yeah what that makes me think about is
even non-communication
can be considered part of the
drop shaping the landscape of
affordances perhaps being communication
of non-linguistic type and so how could
we have a model of communication where
the special cases of which there are
infinite the special cases are
Communications in their embodied sense
and we can also abstract to people who
only communicate through social networks
through breathing the same air
all these kinds of very loose only
ecologically aligned if only on Earth
aligns
views of communication seeing that as
like the field from which different
forms of communication of cognitive
entities arises from rather than
something symbolic and transmissive
which could only be instantiated kind of
from the top down by a symbolic
subsystem or sub functionality
which isn't denied by a bottom-up view
but it's contextualized
as part of a process that includes the
ecology and the shaping of the field of
affordances and Landscapes and the
stigmergy as something fundamental
and that's where the call that's where
the Ecology of the context does act as a
constraint so yeah okay all right
conclusion
so they introduced a pragmatist
conception of communication grounded in
an ecological interpretation of the
active inference framework
there's a lot more to develop
so where do papers end
where do projects begin
right and then they mentioned two
different directions which are uh
relatively well confirmed empirical
results
uh first is the work on joint attention
and seeing joint attention as a relevant
aspect
in relationship to coordination on
landscapes
and relevant for language development
and then the second point of empirical
evidence that they want to bring in is
neuroimaging data showing co-activation
or
partnership in some way of different
parts of the body and brain associated
with certain actions that seem to be
linked in a way that's best understood
or core screened as being ecological or
embedded
and then here is the uh part mentioned
earlier to conclude it is trivially true
that pretty much any episode of
communication can be described as a
transmission of information
as suggested in the section some cases
of communication so no bird call
no bird call
hard to get around that one in practice
maybe there's some theoretical tricks
but
um what if communication is pre-planning
really hear a bird call in five minutes
really want that to happen or make that
happen and then what happens
um however there'd be no communication
if there was no information in some
sense
that is some form of association between
a signal and affordance
which constitute General ecological
information
semiosis
Persian Triad
abductive discussion we had in 47. so
this is the biosemiotic ecological
angle that we came from
last time
and this paper is going to really
highlight the ecological
and the free energy
minimizing aspect Via Field of
affordance modifying
through stigmergic modifications or
other types of communication maybe just
making your body visible in a certain
way
and using that as part of a joint
socially co-enacted free energy
minimization
pointing the way towards models that
would do that but not as the only
endpoint
but it's in a framing where models could
conceivably do that like through
software packages
and model design processes
I sometimes choose words
not carefully and I know that I don't
think that the word trivially was placed
in that last bullet as a as a
as a way of provoking but maybe it was I
think basically
um it's basically true but saying it's
trivially true is like saying okay well
a math proof is Trivial because it just
is there I I think it's sometimes hard
to to
overstate how some of the basics matter
that doesn't mean get locked in just and
then stop because you got the basics
right I mean there's a whole bunch of
stuff that pops out of that and and
included that too if you're looking at
something realistically however
um
I don't know I don't know if it's very
trivial or not like I don't know that
it's that common some of these more
interesting
mathematical proofs
we could say they are because they've
already been proven but that doesn't
mean everybody has access to it or even
understands
the importance of it so that's just a
little side comment because I know I I
catch myself regretting sometimes
describing things in certain ways
all right to defend the trivial I looked
up the definition I really wanted to
know
um it turns out it is originating from
Trivium
which is an introductory curriculum at a
medieval University involving the study
of grammar rhetoric and logic
so
maybe it's it's so trivial
it's just the kind of trivial details
that you end up spending quite a long
time working on awesome good good
defense that would be that would be a
funny interpretation you know bring back
the Trivium
um yeah our hope is that the model it
describes inspires experimental designs
that can lead to such
theoretical or applied treatments okay
what are your thoughts
well as I wrote here I think that means
keeping active inference on the bench
and constrained to a controlled setting
I mean again if you want to be able to
compare to
a control this is
this is your next step however since
when does setting a condition liberate
communication to do what communication
does
which is released understanding and not
just aggregated for the sake of control
and I wrote your time to break out the
meme launches Dan you've got more direct
experience with
with writing about active inference and
memes than I have yes so
that's the slide here we go yeah well
just wanted to kind of explore this and
leave some open space to go into it more
yeah building on the work of our
colleague marigula who is a professor in
Monterey California yeah she had written
about memes as quasi-arguments and about
the kind of space that opens in
between in
enduring the meme and specifically image
meme interpretation or interpolation
process so in addition to or an
alternative to the purely dynamical
descriptive and uh evolutionary Fitness
oriented meme definition commonly used
by Dawkins and all synths
this is a very media and
cognitive interpretation of artifacts
and through a paper in 2021 and in 2022
we used some previous work that had been
done by equiha at all 2020
on a three-tier model of how to frame
complex ecosystems the kinds that people
are usually talking about when they
mention ecosystems like the non-metaphor
if there were a non-metaphor and it
wasn't just app ecosystems and social
ecosystems the one with you know the
trees but don't they all
um three layers being an instrumental
layer of pure observations
basically mapping onto observed States
then a contextual layer which can bring
in some knowledge about how different
measurements or inferences about
measurements are linked like to Common
entities
and then using this type of
statistically inferred information and
augmented information from the
contextual layer to do inference on pure
unobservables those might be things that
are observable but you didn't observe
like the temperature at some point where
there wasn't a thermometer or the true
unobservables could be like propensity
of this Mile Square of land to be used
for this purpose in the next five years
but that's not something that could be
measured there's no measuring device
other than the modeling process but it's
an important modeling process and they
did amazing work connecting complex
systems and ecologies and on the rise in
determined in spirit is discussions of
digital ecosystems and ecological
approaches to communication as noted by
the authors here and hence by extension
ecological approaches to digital
communication
and so we were able to modify or to
translate and respect the ecosystem
Integrity three-tier model provided by
those authors
onto the kinds of digital discourse
analysis platforms that would be aligned
in that ecological interpretation and
way
so I think there'll be a lot to explore
maybe now maybe next time go ahead yes
quick just quickly so would you describe
what you did from a and transition to B
as an inaction
it was an action in the slides software
of one type and then it becomes a
different in action when it is shared as
a asynchronous file or through live
communication with a colleague it's a
different inaction when the preprint is
open source and available immediately
upon completion there are many levels of
in types of inaction
all right
then it closes with a discourse from
skirms scurms 2010 suggests that in any
complex organization
different highlighting information
transmission and processing and
coordination of action
may not be entirely separate
gasp
skirms 1996 and scurms 2010 these are
actually really excellent books I hope
that is not taken as dismissive but it
goes to show what views
are seen as and Justified to be often
needing support
and what that means or why that behavior
is that way what is that linguistic
string for in this
quote from 2022 written
originally in 2010
and then the authors write what
fundamentally matters is the control of
behavior and not the transmission of
information even if the control of
behavior may be described as a form of
information transmission so very much a
syntax semantics question how many bits
is the file
what does the file mean syntax and
semantics
in the specific unfolding of the
interpretation you can take a top-down
overview like 55 of people who did this
also did that and then there's a bottom
up cognitive view which is the
ecological embodied engagement with the
image meme or with something like that
with the animal signal or Mark or smell
and then to paraphrase germs the
information transmission gloss footnote
35 with some Eagan citations
the information transmission gloss on
communication communicative Behavior if
it is to prove useful at all might be
thought of as an aspect of the control
of behavior rather than the other way
around
reversing Primacy but not denying
we propose that conceiving Communication
in such a way provides better insights
into the pragmatic nature of
communicative behavior and its Evolution
as a free energy minimizing activity and
a paper
what do you want to ask
that's basically it we have a few things
written down here 48.1 but what would
you like to add on that I mean what I
like about the conclusion is that they
say I'm I'm I'm taking and paraphrasing
in my own
thinking in my own words
um
just because you transmit doesn't mean
that you're actually
sussing out or determining or or
confirming the difference between play
as one kind of action playing
and then played so they really want to
incorporate that temporal piece which I
think is really smart which again I'm a
I'm a big believer that there's a logic
that
supports that which D limits
which direction you're necessarily uh
asking to look at time are you going
with time and there's only one direction
are you enacting it or are you
delimiting and able to
Place some sort of
um gap between the memorial and the
projectional and the other thing is
um
I think
when you walk when we walk into these
situations and see them as ecologies we
are going to miss things
so I think we just have to accept that
there will be laterals and collaterals
on the margins that will will sort of
bleed into what our regime of attention
is and so I think if you only focus on
the transmission my turn your turn my
turn your turn you don't have a hope of
trying to bring those very important
things that that are essentially
building up whatever you are taking away
from this communication exercise so
again I think that's something important
that they raise in sketching this out
there's actually a benefit or a feature
in not filling it in
to in with too much detail because how
could they every time there's a
communication act going on or a dyad
happening the openness of that
means there's going to be some scale
friendly Fallout that can't be predicted
with certainty so that I really like
their conclusion actually so
yeah there's my there's my thoughts in
those last couple of slides
okay
a lot to think about I guess and discuss
in the coming weeks
I think a few
last pieces here
seeing transmission as enablements
for semantics
and connecting that to the piercing
Triad and abductive logic
and as a uh escaping the nosedive of
descriptionism and reductionism
by holding space for the pragmatics if
nothing else of higher order levels of
analysis and coarse graining so whether
you need to appeal to computational
resources we won't be able to finish the
analysis or other kinds of pragmatics
including meaning as pragmatics in the
socially extended cognitive space then
there's a very rich view in which we
don't need to like reject Digital Signal
processing in order to have an
ecological interpretation
um
I think there's a a few other areas we
can go
into
so with that
um we have there's other relevant Works
to share okay any final final thoughts
no I mean what I appreciate is how uh
how smoothly and quickly we're able to
kind of go through this paper I think
that's a testament to the authors
um being clear about what they wanted to
ascribe and what they wanted people to
be able and extend off of so it kind of
reinforces their idea of this extended
active inference instead of them having
all the answers they just planted some
seeds and let people kind of take it
pop in different directions which I
think would maybe was one of their goals
I don't know
very nice totally agree I agreed that
it's very readable
clear paper
that laid out a nice path with berries
to pick from a lot of footnotes and
paths to explore and it is going to be
great to discuss it in the coming weeks
so Dean thanks so much for the
preparation and for joining live and
we'll see you very soon
same back right back at you buddy take
care peace